whenever something looks interesting
beautiful there's a natural impulse to
want to capture and preserve it which
means in this day and age that we're
likely to reach for our phones and take
a picture though this might seem like an
ideal solution there's a big problem
associated with it we're likely to be so
busy taking the pictures and forget to
look at the world whose beauty and
interests prompted us to take a
photograph in the first place these
problems seem to be very much of today a
consequence of the tiny phones in our
pockets but they were noticed right at
the beginning of the history of
photography when the average camera was
the size of a grandfather clock the
first person to notice them was the
English art critic John Ruskin he was
very impressed by cameras at first but
gradually he grew very suspicious often
believing that they've lined at us to
our surroundings to try to correct this
blindness Ruskin recommended that all of
us take up drawing not with a view to
becoming great artists but simply
because through the act of trying to
recreate on paper what we see in the
world we study it in a way we never do
when we simply take a photograph summing
up what he had attempted to do in four
years of teaching and writing manuals on
drawing Ruskin wrote let two persons go
out for a walk the one a good sketcher
the other having no taste of the kind
let them go down a green lane there will
be a great difference in the scene as
perceived by the two individuals the one
will see a lane and trees he will
perceive the trees to be green though he
will think nothing about it he will see
that the Sun shines in that it has a
cheerful effect and that's all but what
will a sketcher see his eye is
accustomed to search into the cause of
beauty and penetrate the minut as parts
of loveliness he looks up and observes
how the showery and subdivided sunshine
come sprinkled down among the gleaming
leaves overhead till the air is filled
with an emerald light he will see here
and there a bow emerging from the veil
of leaves he will see the jewel
brightness of the emerald Moss and the
variegated and fantastic lichens white
and blue purple and red all mellowed and
mingled into a single garment of beauty
then come the cavernous trunks and the
twisted roots that grasp with their
snake-like coils at the steep Bank whose
turfy slope is inlaid with flowers of a
thousand dyes is this not worth seeing
yet if you are not a sketcher you will
pass along the green lane and when you
come home again have nothing to say or
to think about it but that you went down
such-and-such a Lane
you